hi I'm Nick Gillespie with Reason TV and
today we are talking to the independence
it's on Monday Tuesday Wednesday and
Friday at 9 p.m. Eastern Time on Fox
Business channel it's Kennedy Camille
Foster and reasons I'm Matt Welch you've
been on the air since December Kennedy
who's been the best guest that you've
had and who's the worst we were we were
talking about this and Kristin Cavallari
actually might take the crown for both
who is she and what did she do Kristin
Cavallari is famous for being on the MTV
reality show the hills and Laguna Beach
when she was in high school she has
since married Jay Cutler and they've had
a child and she's pregnant with child
number two and in the course of the
interview I asked her if she was a
libertarian and she said yes and then we
realized later she was confused about
the definition of the word libertarian
and she didn't she thought we were
saying liberal and and so I went through
you know the gamut of questions for a
libertarian mom do you believe in
same-sex marriage yes she does do you
believe in legalizing marijuana and she
seemed to and then I asked her if she
vaccinates her kids and she said no and
that created a firestorm which was great
for us but her publicist was very upset
with the interview camille talked a
little bit about what are the issues I
mean you guys are the independence
you're politically independent you're
libertarian-leaning what are the issues
that are most driving a kind of interest
you know that's driving people out of
the Republican and Democratic Party and
towards a third way I think a lot of the
privacy issues national security issues
for sure the the various Wars and
military conflicts that are going on but
certainly the NSA revelations have been
a popular topic for us to discuss on the
show and so is that is that age based I
mean clearly a lot of younger people
that's the issue that's like turned a
light bulb on for them that Obama is as
bad as Bush in a lot of ways but is it
also for older people as well who maybe
aren't as you know interested in that
well I think older folks are interested
in it as well they also have some
context for it they can relate it to the
Pentagon Papers or some other thing that
they've seen in the past and say yeah
you know this guy is very much just like
the other guys and by the way NSA stuff
has been really fertile grounds for
disagreement with other Fox and Fox
business ho
so you know I I know and Matt and
Camille have experienced this when you
go on other shows other people will try
and attack you for being the libertarian
and having those civil liberties views
wanting to protect civil liberties so
that in itself makes it very exciting
because it there's a surprising number
of people who don't share our opinion
and I don't know if it's necessarily
generational but you know they see that
there is a split between freedom and
safety and they'd much rather err on the
side of safety Matt talk a little bit of
bad I mean obviously as the
editor-in-chief of Reason magazine
you're you're planning out issues going
forward for the show what are what are
the big issues that you think you're
going to be looking at and coming back
to over the next couple of months reason
we do theme issues pretty regularly we
have new one coming out about video
games we kind of go through the same
thing on our Friday shows we do news the
day on Monday Tuesday and Wednesday and
Friday we try to do it based on a theme
kind of like John Stossel show and one
of our first Friday shows was on race
and Camille insisted that we have a
segments kind of to the chagrin of
Kennedy myself that we have a segment on
the n-word which he then said he gave me
license but I'm not but it really
affected people in a way like they
hadn't seen that subject talked about in
that way before and we revisited to it I
don't think when we were planning the
show that we expected this to be
something that goes in the news but if
you think about modern politics and
democratic politics in particular so
much of it is based on kind of the war
on women and they all these people are
racist it comes up constantly so we try
to address it in a way it's not
necessarily the anti MSNBC way but like
how do real humans talk about it well we
will leave it there I want to thank Matt
Welch Kennedy and Camille Foster from
the independence it's on Monday Tuesday
Wednesday and Fridays on Fox Business at
9:00 p.m. eastern time and then it's
rerun throughout the week thanks guys so
much and continued success
you